[Musique]
c'est autour d'un bon café que les
nouveaux résidents de la maison des
accueillants familiaux font connaissance
inauguré il ya deux semaines cette
nouvelle structure à taille humaine peut
accueillir une douzaine de personnes
âgées
le vice président du département jean
marie virapoullé est venu souhaiter la
bienvenue aux accuse ont passablement
ensemble en famille parce que la masse
est une famille une famille avec les
accueillant les accueillis c'est de la
convivialité et aujourd'hui on est venus
les accueillir
justement pour leur montrer qu'on est à
leurs côtés leur montrer que le côté
humain est essentiel pour nous que
l'objectif pour nous c'est vraiment le
bien-être la bientraitance la
bienveillance de auprès des personnes
âgées qui en ont bien besoin
voilà ait pu les connaître avoir une
relation avec à la meuf de saint-andré
il y également 4 accueillant des hommes
ou des femmes eux aussi nouveaux
locataires dans cette maison il prépare
les lieux pour que chacun trouve
rapidement les repères du quotidien
j'aime bien donner c'est ce monde de ce
manque de chaleur qu'ils ont les
personnes âgées ou qui quoi que ce soit
et elle venir le rassurer aussi ce point
est donc mais c'est ça qui m'a ramené à
lörrach commencé voilà il va de vous
retrouver ici dans cette nouvelle maison
avec des nouveaux à cuba sa voix ça va
puisque bon ben on s'entend bien là tout
le monde participe bombe à celle que les
débuts on verra un petit peu au fur et à
mesure qu est ce qu'on pourra faire au
fur et à mesure ensemble mais tout le
monde est vraiment tout dias mais de 2,2
des boues débuter une nouvelle vie quoi
je dirais voilà la maison des
accueillants familiaux est une structure
innovante
une première à la réunion et en
métropole ce dispositif a vu le jour
grâce au travail collaboratif du
département de la réunion et du ccas de
la commune de saint-andré
[Musique]